hey and this is Pete peppers from candy
crush soda saga tips calm and I was
talking with some players in my Facebook
group today about lives and how to
manage them the best and there's it's a
little different on Facebook if you play
the game primarily on Facebook and and
on the mobile app so I was gonna go
through just how to manage them best on
the different platforms so over here I
have I had just opened my facebook my
game and Facebook and I got this pop-up
the son live so I was in the middle
doing that so I thought I would probably
pause there so you could see it once a
day it seems like you get this send
lives and it has two tabs one for all
friends and one for soda friends if you
send it to all friends that's gonna it's
gonna probably be a nuisance to a lot of
people who don't play they're gonna get
an invitation to play the game and it's
gonna say it's from you so what I do is
I um take all the people on that tab and
then go to the soda friends and I send
them all a life and the reason why you
do that is or why it's a good idea to do
that I should say is that when those
players get those lives and they accept
them
you'll get one back like these lives I
have waiting for me I never asked for
lives I never have to because I have so
many friends at play and because I
always send them back so these are just
all always coming in like um I don't
need lives right now but this is doesn't
matter I'm just gonna accept them all
anyways as I do that it sends one back
to all five of these people alright and
with Facebook when you plan Facebook
this is the biggest difference you can't
Bank the lives anyways so if I had
refreshed the game without sending those
back to those players they just would
have disappeared and inevitably since I
have a cycle going with a lot of lives
coming back I would have more lives
when I needed him but it would slow down
the process of him coming back because I
wouldn't be sending any out and then you
have this tab here and this will send
them back to all the people who
requested lives so at the minimum you
always want to do that but when you're
playing on Facebook I say that once
you're done playing with it playing
obsession that you should send except
all the ones you have you can't save
them so you're kind of being a bad
neighbor if you don't um send them back
because nobody gets a lodge then and it
will also hurt you later because you
won't have your normal lives way before
you want to come in and then you'll have
to request them of course if you need
lives
you can request them you hit on the
button here it will bring up this tab
ask friends and then you can it's the
same thing you don't really want to ask
the all friends because they don't
necessarily play some of them do because
they'll be people on both lists but um
you know what I used to do done tick
this and then if I know some certain
people around I might I might pick them
out specifically you know like if I
wanted to do send a request to my super
admin super super oh so I would just
click on her name but um you know you
can also if you want just do that and
hit the select all button and you can
ask all your friends who play to get one
and so it's a pretty straightforward
process I'm not gonna do it because
it'll take all that time to ask me about
what it said in certain people so here
we go my my box is now empty and I'll
refresh it and I'll show you what I mean
so I had about thirty something like
thirty requests when I opened that time
it varies you know sometimes you have
more sometimes have less I haven't been
playing soda on Facebook much
couple days because I wasn't using I was
playing on king.com and it's it's a
different it's a different platform
there the lives that you get there from
other people that play on it so that's a
whole different ballgame but you can see
even though my box was empty now it has
another requested so I'll send that out
and if I'm playing all the time and I
have a lot going back and forth I always
have a bunch arrives in there so that's
basically it you know as I'm going to
open up the app now this is the mobile
app one thing to keep in mind with
Facebook is just that you want to you
want to perpetuate a you know a cycle
going in and out so you can't you can't
save many ways to have sent them all
back when you close it so that way won't
you'll be saving lives and more lives
will be coming in now you can see it's a
lot different on the mobile on my app I
have four hundred and fifty lives or 450
requests and
I'm using an emulator and I can't change
the orientation so I can only see it a
small part of my list if you look at it
and landscape or me the portrait it'll
it'll show more but you can see I have a
bunch of lives and they're banked inside
here so if I just went ahead and played
these five lives maybe I accepted a
couple more in the process I could close
the app and then come back and all this
stuff and still be sitting there that's
why I have 400 so the problem with that
is this map doesn't where this doesn't
scroll at all right so at the very
bottom we know from looking at our other
mailbox we have a blue button that says
send lives to friends who asked but we
can't see it right now so I don't play a
whole lot of mobile but if I do what I
do is I'll accept the ones at the top of
the list I mean obviously I'll use them
while I'm playing but before I close the
game what I'll do is I'll accept a
couple off the top or anywhere in the
list but just you know make space
collecting these ones because they have
less originally
and like I said when you look at a
portrait it won't be as bad you'll be
able to accept less of them but this is
a how-to video so and honestly I don't
ever worry about lives because I always
have them coming in so you know one way
that you can do that is you can join our
group on Facebook and you can add a lot
of friends who play and that is one
thing that I find helpful I also you
know make videos and like helping people
out with tips and things so I enjoy
having lots of friends who play because
they get a lot of feedback on what
people are having trouble with and
things like that all right so this might
take a sec I'm gonna pause the video and
get it all right so I had to accept
quite a few of them but then eventually
you can see now I had the send button
down here and I hadn't signed into the
app for a while so I have a two hundred
eleven friends who asked it past me four
lives and looks like somebody just sent
me some more so that pushed it down
again it's kind of funny so I'll send
this and then I'll give all those people
who need them lives back and whenever
they get them they'll collect them and
it will send me another one that'll be
up here it was kind of funny when I was
accepting all those requests because I
could see in the off-screen here in the
Facebook tab that I was getting all
these different people sending me
requests before lives
doesn't one sender that's that's alright
I'll fix it later so that's pretty much
all there is to it always send to your
friends when you get the chance in the
beginning always help them out when you
can by sending the Mac with the blue
button you know if you have to accept
some requests so that you can see that
it's just it just makes the game more
fun for everybody and as you can see the
cycle is all these things that are
coming up down here telling me that
people are sending me lives so even
though this was empty a couple minutes
ago now I have some lives to play if I
want to play so that's about it I'm
gonna write these tips out too and make
a page but I doubt if you have any
questions you can leave them in the
comments please like the video and share
it with your friends if you think you're
gonna help them out and subscribe to our
channel so you get all the latest videos
like this and our level videos as soon
as they come up thanks